We've discussed two of the components so far. First, we had the affective
component, which was our feelings and emotions. And as we just saw with my
example of the red wings, we had the behavioral component. And this is a
tendency to act in a certain way toward something. Clearly, you could see how I
act towards the red wings. And the third component, of our attitudes, is the
cognitive component. And this is our thoughts, beliefs, and ideas about
something. Our attitudes can vary in terms of how heavily each component is
weighed. That is, you may have a more cognitive component for some attitudes,
for example, maybe the best way to make cheese fondue. It may be more heavily
weighted from the cognitive component as opposed to something such as your
attitude towards abortion, which may have a more affective component. Although
most of our basic attitudes may be instinctive, we do know that some of our
attitudes are learned.